congratulations first of all on such an
amazing and Powerful film and for all
the success you've already had um just
want to point out for you all in case
you weren't already aware that uh
earlier this year at Sundance that Leo
was awarded the best actor jury prize
that's not exactly
the that's amazing That's History making
too is the first trans person to be
awarded that award so that's really
quite amazing so congrats to the team
I'm
[Applause]
V I'm the writer and director and I've
directed a few shorts but my main source
of income and what I do for living is
key
gripping yeah I'm Leo um um I play fena
and uh I I've been an actor my whole
life I was a child actor on Broadway for
a little while and a salsa dancer and
then my dad was stressed I was going to
become like a drug addicted child star
and so I stopped acting until I
graduated and I've worked on a lot of
short films too many to list but uh very
grateful for this as my first feature
one of which just got nominated for
Student Academy yeah true which is so
czy yeah this short that I did called
Skin by a trans filmmaker a trans
masculine uh director and
cinematographer uh you haven't seen it I
don't think it got nominated and might
be winning I think it's going to
win are there any voters
in yeah but he's really talented his
name is also
Leo and he goes to AFI and he's trans
and
he's
anyways yeah sorry sorry
sorry but he so I feel like that's dope
um it's very cool to and Leo I'll there
Leo I'm Alexander sigm I'm one of the
lead producers of this movie uh and my
background is really as uh development
exec mostly if you go back far enough I
studied to be a diplomat and I was a
cartographer
the we're all learning different things
each that never ever come
up I see see
you my name is Andrew carlberg I'm an
executive producer on the film uh
started out in television on an ABC
television show called castle and have
been an independent producer for the
last 11 or so years and I produced a
different short called Skin that won the
Oscar a couple years ago
and I know so we're
ready it's time for another skin doing
that
SK exactly uh sist Howard I'm a
executive producer on this beautiful
beautiful film and uh I come from film
by way of punk rock music and
uh EXA there you go uh yeah made some
films and very excited to be part of
this film yeah s
up thank you all no Oscars yet also
veryl
director Hulu this year thank you thank
you yeah you all have very interesting
background for sure um and I just want
to point out because we're at film
independent and that this film was also
especially exciting for us to screen
because m is a part of our fiscal
sponsorship program and also Andrew and
Silas are alums of our uh a few of our
different programs um maybe we could
just briefly mention that too what
programs you've been in I uh yeah did
the uh director's lab um with a project
about Billy Tipton who was a jazz
musician who um discovered to be trans
after he died in 1989 and um and then
FasTrack also with that same project and
still in touch with a lot of my labmates
and mentors from that it was a really
like great Community Building U
experience for me yeah and I was part of
FastTrack in
2014 but my relationship with film
independent goes back to 2008 where I
volunteered at the Spirit Awards and was
in charge of opening and closing the
curtain for for luminar such as Brad and
Angelina when they
were and was standing for Brad P I was
just standing for Brad they wanted
someone that kind of looked
[Laughter]
right I like um well wonderful thank you
it's great to have you back and great to
have this project here for a number of
reasons um Bo maybe we could talk I
listened to your NPR interview and you
mentioned which you all should listen
it's a wonderful short interview I
learned it's actually it was a 30 minute
interview but it's an 8-minute interview
that you can find online um you spoke at
that point about the original
inspiration for this story which was
about your sister and um I was I was
curious to hear more about that and um
if you could share a little bit about
the original inspiration and kind of how
it grew from there into what it is yeah
um for sure I think when there's a
smaller so intimate Gathering as much
I'm a little more open about my life but
I had a tough upbringing I left my home
earlier than any normal people do I left
chill and I left behind a little sister
and at the time I was more focused on my
survival and staying alive and when I
was graduating college the senior year
just kind of started really missing home
and really missing her and wrote this
kind of love letter to her and to the
idea of mentorship and the idea of trans
people as amazing mentors that I think
sometimes we as queer people think that
we can't Mentor someone who isn't queer
but there's a lot of knowledge that that
we can give so I just wanted to kind of
think okay what would it be like if she
just appeared would she care would she
not how would I treat her could I be
helpful so then that was the Genesis and
it grew to include a lot of things that
I was really afraid of like am I ever
going to be desired by a partner again
am I going to be loved by the rest of my
family what is society going to think
and just kind of investigating fear
really killing people with kindness like
my character is like really trying to be
empathetic with the father character and
the ex and everybody and just kind
of getting in their in their head and
understanding a little bit more yeah
definitely and we were talking a bit
outside about how fast of process this
has been you were saying yes and no yes
and no well yes I guess once you started
shooting I mean that that that their
film shot less than a year ago actually
in August last year right August 28th
wasth
29th 29th yeah yeah it's been crazy yeah
and so from there from your script I was
curious to hear you know as you were
editing rapidly um and I imagine you've
been through many drafts of your script
just what where where we're left with
the story now how did that kind of
progress um anything you'd like to share
about that how the story changed over
time well I wrote it six years ago was
quite different the dad was a
grandma I didn't know that yeah she was
like a Latin American
Grandma different story um
so from the page like the final script
to this it didn't change much I think a
lot changed kind of a lot and not that
much when you got cast and you kind of
brought all of your energy and we
created together with f it was so that
was a big change um but the page to this
it's pretty similar I mean six years of
from writing it to now there was just a
lot of time to sharpen my knives you
could say so um and you you know this
but you guys don't know this we shot and
we had two weeks put together a rough
cut to get into Sundown so like it was a
pretty quick editing process and I think
the amount of time that it was
marinating and the fact that it was a
24-hour linear story cuz you can't
really change where things are you can
delete or keep things but you can't
really change it or reinvent it so that
was really helpful in the process of
being able to do that yeah yeah
absolutely well you started to speak
about it but involving Leo in the
process um can you speak a little bit
about when you came on the project and
also how you've been involved with
shaping this story yeah
um I I received a lot of DMS on
Instagram from friends of mine being
like I saw this casting call is this you
and I was like what and then I read it
and it's true fena on the page as he was
described and I have a lot of
similarities in our identity and you
know vuk and I also as humans do um you
know it was
like Chilean and Serbian I'm Puerto
Rican and Greek it's like kind of
similar you
know like Latin and
European um and then it's like you know
sharp but tender and I'm sharp but
tender then it was like shooting in
Bushwick and Ridgewood and I lived in
Ridgewood for six years that's my
neighborhood it just was this sort of
for me it felt like when I saw this
casting call it was like a a message
from the cosmos like that's how powerful
it felt just reading that and so I
emailed vuk and I was like you don't
know me but please just give me this
part I'll do you know whatever and then
he sent me the script and of course like
it was even better than I had imagined
like the script the movie is really
beautiful but vuk is a poet on the page
and for me I love texts and I love
reading and I love when writers really
care about the language that they're
using and and he just did such an
amazing job at making you feel the
heartbeat of the characters on the page
and so I just did my self tape and like
you know pray literally was like I
really I'm just I need this because as a
transactor
you know I had been working
professionally for a long time but this
was the first featurelength script that
I had the opportunity to read where I
could be a lead character and my primary
motivation as a character had nothing to
do with my gender identity it was about
me picking up my dad from the airport me
trying to have a relationship with my
sister and my ex-boyfriend and yes my
transness comes up but ultimately it's a
a human story and I'm not to f is not
tokenized and that was so exciting to me
and inspiring to me to be able to be a
part of a project like that and show
what I can do as an actor because I know
I mean so many transactors are typ cast
in this very particular way um or have
been up until this point I think that's
really changing so yeah and then I got
involved we didn't have very much time
to rehearse cuz it's a tiny film and you
know like people are doing
everything um so we had a few table
reads with the other actors and then we
did go camping for four we oh we did do
that yeah we did that nice just us too
uh we can tell you guys about that later
um yeah yeah it's a long story so yeah
that's uh yeah it was great it awesome
yeah I mean it's so powerful you you
just spoke to it but I think just
getting to be in your shoes and the way
that it's written and the way that it's
performed I think just really takes you
you on the ride of how it feels to be
you and creates a lot of empathy for
your character cuz you're just strapped
into your 24 hours um so I think that's
super powerful approach and personal
that's what I like about what Cinema can
do and how it can be effective um
Alexander um I'd love to hear about how
you got involved with this project and
what Drew you to want to be involved
yeah I as I I'm happy to talk about that
something that I V didn't even know
until recently I think when we were
doing another Q&A about something but um
I
uh I I started my career really at
National Geographic magazine so I had
this like very journalism background I
produced art and stuff there and then I
was a development exec at Disney
Animation studio and uh after I left
there I left there to be an independent
producer and mut was one of the first
projects I read and it was through
another producer of the movie Stephen
Scott scarpulla and uh just because I
think of my background at n in my
childhood I've always been really pass
about passionate about underrepresented
voices and I'd never read a scripts like
before I was had a different title at
the time but it was I'd never read
anything like it Kil it's like the
Chilean word for M um and I called
Stephen who had sent it to me who had
met Ste uh vuk on set of another project
and and um I was like Stephen I have to
make this movie like I have to be a part
of this movie and I like bullied
Stephen into like getting us on getting
V to come let us come on board the
script um and that was five years ago
and he wrote it six years ago that's
five years ago and it was a really long
process of of of making it but I think I
knew from the minute I read it that i'
had never seen anything like it and I
think like Leo said like V's words are
very poetic and um I just wanted to be a
part of something that would um change
conversation um and I didn't know that
it would but I do think that it has and
I'm really excited to see what comes of
of this round in the future and how it
can impact and influence what stories
are told and how yeah definitely I'm I'm
excited for it to come out it comes out
on Friday in Los Angeles so be sure to
tell your friends and
about it um it's already in New York
it's already playing in New York and
it's also playing in France in the
theatrical so if you have any french fan
friends and family encourage them cuz
all the if you don't already know the
the box office of especially for films
like this really makes a difference so
maybe even just buy a ticket even if
you're not going to
go it would be a really nice way to
support this team and and this indie
film kind of making its way and to have
a theatrical is a really big deal is
always a big deal but I think especially
a big deal in this moment um but yeah
Andrew can you talk a little bit about
how you got involved in the role you've
been playing I I mean Alexander and I
were fairly new friends we met at a
mutual friend short film screening which
I am such a proponent we were talking
earlier of short film making because I
think it brings people together in such
a quick and fast way no matter how it
comes together but Alexander had told me
about mut and it had been on my radar um
for several months and then I remember
at one point he was just like we're
shooting in a couple weeks and we don't
have all the money and I was like girl
like I was like honey that is really
close and so I help just connect a few
dots silus was already on board I was a
fan of his television career and Jake
had already come out and so I knew that
had like a stamp of approval from
somebody that I also knew knew to be an
amazing filmmaker and um I just honestly
Alexander was the lead producer but I
just helped connect a couple dots in the
fin and he was like a confidant for me
this is a really hard movie to make like
Leo was saying it's was a small crew we
shot uh including um pickup days or re-
shoots we did 24 days we had over 30
locations which is insane 37 locations
which is insane it's you when you have
money and we didn't have money and there
was like one like he was checking on me
i' never leted produ a movie before so I
was like leading him all these things
like is this the right thing am might do
it's never the right thing but you have
to it was like one day he called me and
he's like are you okay I'm like no the
PA just hit a car with a
TR we are in a location we never scouted
at we just showed up today here it's the
first camera assistant the
house marking up the walls the roommate
is not happy I'm like sitting on the
curb just like vening to him
that's what producing is I I'm thrilled
just to be a part of the journey and um
I'm so happy with what everybody's
created I think it's so incredibly
powerful and the community that's come
around it has been really and there's
been between film independent and
Sundance and and all sorts of stuff
there's been so many like Circle backs
in life that have been really rewarding
to
see great silence my turn well I I feel
so uh lucky to be as any part of this
film and associated with this film I
think I met I met vuk through Ira Z
right we met in Toronto when you were
premiering kid like Jak kid like Jake
yeah so um yeah it's uh I I come to film
making through Community really and
through like a queer community and Film
Community and you know as a trans
director um you know who's really worked
a lot to tell stories that are not
explaining narratives because I just
think it's a it's a disservice to the
the audience you know to do that it's a
power Dynamic and and it keeps everyone
at a distance and um I it's just been
really it's so important that stories
are told authentically and when I watch
this film I just feel that so solidly um
there's just such a nuance and and such
a it makes it so Universal and and you
know just the the ways that our bodies
have shown and the ways that like
mentoring is shown and you know I've
worked I've been lucky enough to work in
in a lot of TV and stuff that is also
looked at um bringing stories to to the
center but um but really this feels like
it's told from the ground up
authentically and it's just such a big
win and I I hope it paves away for more
I was I was at Sundance 22 years ago
with my film and it was um we were uh we
directed it my best friend and I
directed it and acted it and everything
we we code out on it and uh and you know
we were trying so desperately to get
people to understand a different concept
of gender and I just remember doing an
NPR interview which was probably quite
different than yours which was oh my god
listen
to we wrote this whole thing about
gender a note on gender because we were
just trying to get them to not call it a
lesbian movie and um and so uh and uh
they were just basically like but will
straight people watch this movie and um
I say this a lot so sorry if anyone's
heard me say but basically we're just
like we're not French we watch French
movies we're not a shark we watch Jaws
like it just doesn't matter story it's a
story need to be the thing that's the
whole point of a story is that you can
go other places and connect in ways that
you never thought you could and um I was
so excited to watch the reception of
this film because it was such a big win
you know to be in competition to get
this award I'm just I'm just so excited
that I get to see that and and be part
of that and yeah I'm just so moved by it
I really it's just such a beautiful film
it's just such an important and
Beautiful film so yeah I really I hope
it just yeah I'm excited for your next
film amen thank you I think
even even if you hadn't been involved in
the movie you were involved in it
happening because you were a role model
for me before I even met you I'm
standing on your shoulders you
know I me so much thank you yes
sh
feelings it's obvious that there's a ton
of Love around this film and I feel I
feel that when when I was watching the
film I was just super drawn in even from
the very first shot actually kind of
hooked me I don't know if that was
always supposed to be the first shot or
not
but well it drew it was literally coming
you know drawing you in literally and I
thought it was really effective I was
immediately interested intrigued by what
was happening and and we were kind of
just being led into a a story that was
already in motion and I thought that was
super effective um all right last couple
questions um let's talk a little bit
about the title sure and yeah it's I I
love the title it has lots of different
layers to it um can you share a bit
about what you were thinking and naming
with that yeah I can give you the long
answer or the short answer what do you
want maybe the
[Music]
shorter the long answer includes Chile
but the short answer is um I'm a m uh
outside of being a trans I think a trans
well I've never seen being a trans man
but I
think I think everybody's a mut and I
think mutus the inbetweenness of things
just is a really beautiful umbrella term
in a way for people who are trans who
are mixed ethnicity who are don't find
themselves with
um I don't know a specific home I don't
know I think it's just we all monuts
especially right now in the United
States more and
more so that's the short one that's the
short you could throw in a little bit
long cuz you were sharing something
really interesting outside too I thought
that's Qui in between this just about
that it's more I mean you were kind of
just saying that but it's more and I and
I got this from the film but it's it's
great to articulate it too of just your
intention of it not and it's obvious
that it's not just about being a trans
movie it's more than that and it's about
this mix of identities for for Leo's
character and um and I think that that
makes it also super relatable because
most people are a big mix of identities
um whether or not they are also trans so
I think that that allows us in in a way
um for people outside of the trans
Community as well yeah well what is I
think what I was saying outside was
that I think it was related to what it
was called in France in France the movie
is called 24 hours in New York New York
sells in France apparently so and it's
been going well over there but in the
beginning we were like can we call it
something like mut like a mixed race dog
right and the word is b which is bastard
which is a little too insulting for me
but what I like about mut is that it's
usually in Chile Where I Come From it's
usually a word that's used to attack
someone um and I think when you use the
things that are used against you as
armor it's kind of the the only thing
you can do right say be proud of the
fact that you are mix or you are not
really fitting anywhere so is that part
of the longer answer
yeah um and let's just touch briefly on
the beautiful
cinematography um can you it's just
amazing you know I just there's scenes
that are very ordinary in a way that you
see in movies all the time just really
stood out for instance I just remember
from watching it the the scene with the
sister with your sister where you're
sitting on the hood of the car but the
coverage is so beautiful you both look
so beautiful and stunning and yeah I
just love to hear about your your visual
approach to the storytelling and kind of
getting inside of the the character's
experience yeah that's that's kind of a
hard qu I'm just being honest it's kind
of a hard question I think a lot of it
is very subconscious but I will answer
it yeah I think Matthew poier is amazing
um I really want to do my next feature
with him but I I
think my eight years of Genie experience
and I've gaffed features I've done a lot
of things I think it wasn't until Matt
Was preparing for his next feature that
he called me and he was like dude we had
such a shorthand for all of our
conversations that we didn't even
realize how easy it was to talk about
lighting and how much more trusting I
was to do scenes completely in
silhouette you know like that wasn't I
wasn't freaking out cuz I couldn't see
my character's faces if anything I liked
that their bodies were talking in almost
like puppets right like shadow puppets
and that was really exciting for me so I
think my background just allowed for a
little more of trust in that department
and and just we had an amazing gaffer
she was awesome you know and I think I
was excited I talked to Matt he was the
captain of that ship and I was the
captain of this ship and together we
were a pirate ship and like I was
excited to say you you're amazing at
what you do that's why I trust you now
go do your your best right yeah um and I
was excited to not touch
lights I do so if I could build on that
I would say that like uh vuk is also a
very visual person like you know what
you like and you know what you don't
like and like he often describes things
like that is ugly but it's beautiful
because it's ugly you know and I think
he and and Matthew really sought out a
lot of of places that added richness to
the texture of a scene you know and
shooting a movie like this at a really
low budget is really hard because you
don't have all the choices in the world
you know they could find a beautiful
place and then I call and try to
negotiate to shoot there and I get
$20,000 a day and get great guys find
another spot you know um and so that was
like made it a challenge but I think
that like again buas is a very is very
visually driven and I think that
complimented well with Matt who has a
really great aesthetic and this was
Matthew's first feature also
um and we we pushed each other a lot
yeah and I think that was a great
discovery and bonding for for you guys
and I I I just want to ask about like
being having gap for so long and
understanding lighting and um yeah how
many conversations you had because it
definitely feels like that played a big
part into the not that many I think it
was like you like lighting you're good
at it good next right right with Matt we
actually spent the first the first month
talking about the movie we went scene by
scene getting on the same page emotion
we didn't talk about lights we talk
about references nothing wasn't until he
understood exactly how I felt that start
talking and he's a white sis straight
man I think his first his first question
to me was what is the trans gaze and I
was like I have no idea let's
figure it out what is what the trans G
oh yeah good question who knows nobody
yeah but just kind of talking about that
and and dissecting that's so great
because it's such an emotive lighting
and so that sense that you talked about
the emotion for and that day in the car
was a really hard day because again
small team V and Matt did a lot of The
Scouting and they picked a beautiful
location right next to a train
stop not only that was there train going
by every like 15 or 20 minutes but like
towards the end every two minutes we're
new
city the actors are trying to deliver
these
monolog it's like old for train and I'm
like oh sure 20 time like there other
crazy things there was like there's a
beautiful Matt had this like beautiful
in book had this beautiful idea with
these kids going by on the bikes kids
Alex yes we need kids we need kids right
now like okay I'm trying to cast kids
but like the way that like the day shook
out like we plan cast the kids that show
up later in the day but they wanted to
do that shot first and we get to the
location there's like kids playing on
the corner and I was like I'm so sorry
I'm not a creep can you introduce me to
your
parents and they're like talking to
their parents and like we're shooting a
movie can you just sign this waiver we
would love your kids to be in the movie
and then like they were just like kids
on the street riding their own bikes and
their own scooters and we did it over
and over again and there's this great
opening shot to panning toena and Zoe
sitting on the roof and then like we
when we were trying to rob the day it
was such a long day it was week one of
the shoot and we had to move the car so
that you would have this beautiful
lighting with the with the trees so
we're parked in the middle of the road
and we're doing the last shot and then
so and starts like mowing their
lawn no one even has a lawn you're like
how are you mowing your
lawn was watering his garden and
singing and Leo was like excuse me for
trying to do the movie can you just hold
a minute York doesn't give a and then
last the last part of that day the fifth
floor of the apartment building someone
starts blaring classical music like we
could not get a break and like we
couldn't figure out where it was coming
from that was a really really hard day I
don't know if we have time that I think
was day four that was that's the day I
know you were suffering a lot but that's
the day that I was like Leo is a star he
can carry this movie on his shoulders
yeah and I even though you were
suffering through it melting you that
day I feel like it clicked I feel like
the character clicked in you and you
also came up to me at the end of the day
and said I can control my eyebrows
now like I figured it out we don't move
anymore but it was a hard day but it
really for me was a before and after
moment in terms of like
where yeah that's amazing I mean that's
wild to hear you can't tell that all
that was going on and yeah it was just
reminded me too of how CNF you really
put Leo through Fina through the the
ringer you know with this day and Leo
you did such an amazing job just kind of
Landing these big moment one moment
after another and like each you know
meaningful and serious and vulnerable
and you just kept Landing them it's just
I believed you all the way through so
amazing work
yeah any last final final thoughts that
we didn't talk about that you want to
share with everyone I mean I can keep
talking I think we're probably out of
time yeah um well thank you all for
coming
[Music]
tonight